bonsoir téléspectateurs de la deuxième
chaîne j'espère que vous avez pu
profiter des conseils de vos radios
électricien pour vérifier cet après midi
le réglage de vaud récepteur voici le
programme que vous pourrez recevoir ce
soir sur le canal 22 bande 4,625 ligne à
partir de 20h30
tout d'abord un film burlesque de court
métrage de la série félix de christian
duval ex
un quart d'heure plus tard une émission
de variétés de daniel labre réalisé par
jean charles l'agneau qui a pour titre
trois années trois succès ensuite de 21h
à 21h50 opéra croquis le petit musicien
d'après penney scénario et dialogues
pierre gillot et emile noël réalisation
jean marie coll de fille rendez vous si
vous le désirez à 20h30 sur la deuxième
chaîne ce soir au revoir et à tout à
l'heure